and we end tonight with this the  ultimate robot showdown coming to las  vegas we have a preview of the dome that  is actually being set up for the  battlebots 2021 world championship in  fact there are more than 65 teams coming  from all over the world they're going to  go head-to-head with their fighting  machines that's going to start on monday  and for the first time the championship  will be filmed right here in las vegas  coming to see it live is like nothing  you've ever seen before you smell it you  feel it the bleachers rumble you see how  big the robots are you see the  competitors frantically working the  remote controls to get the robot to  fight it better and better it's amazing  to see it live is like nothing else  he can really sell it right the 2021  battlebots world championship will air  on discovery later this year you can see  it live there's 18 shows over the next  couple weeks they still got tickets too